how're you doing I'm doing my name is
Orlando Baxter and if you can't tell by
my accent I'm black I had a pretty
strange incident happened to me this
past summer I walked into a store asked
his woman at the counter if she could
point me in the hour to sunblock was
that and she looked at me and said for
what I was annoyed so I was like cuz I
got a white girl tied up in my trunk cuz
why should I be the only one
uncomfortable in the situation and she
goes oh my god I'm sorry I didn't mean
it like that please forgive me I did but
I did think it was a little bit weird
because if I did have a white girl tied
up in my trunk
she didn't care and then she goes you
know I just I just didn't know I didn't
I didn't know black people use sunblock
I was curious I said would you think we
use she goes no I just thought you guys
had the ability
I said ability like a superhero goes no
no no I just thought you guys have the
ability to absorb the Sun what I've
never heard that before in my life I
just looked at this lady I said listen
lady I don't know where you get your
information from but just because we're
docketing you doesn't mean our skins
made out of solar panels you think black
people go to the beach all day to charge
up just be laying on
[Applause]
[Music]
just laying there come on son give it to
me so I can run faster before I became a
full-time comic I was actually a
full-time in-school suspension teacher
at a high school that was a tough job
and you know because they always say you
need training there's no training for it
right I was like use your instinct I'm
like that's ridiculous because what have
two kids are fighting and your instinct
tells you to put five dollars down on a
big girl now the principal was all upset
I can't believe you only put $5 down on
that girl you know she's undefeated some
days were terrifying I remember one time
the principal escorted a kid in my class
he escorted kid he said mr. Baxter this
is derek derekson making cat noises in
class he's not on his meds today we're
gonna leave him here with you as a
safety precaution and I was like what
about my goddamn safety because I never
worked weak-ass before I'm not a cat
whisperer
right ten minutes lady sends another kid
cause he wore pajamas to school you know
can't wear pajamas to school kid was
very upset he's like yo yo this is crazy
son
yo why can't we wear pajamas to school I
didn't know the answer to this question
so I said what most teachers say when we
don't know the answer to the question I
said why do you think you can't wear
pajamas to school and before you can
respond cat boy said you can't wear
pajamas cause they afraid your penis
might pop out
and I wanted to I wanted to yell at him
for being inappropriate but my instinct
was like that's a pretty good guide a
mess
here's the problem though to keep with
the pajamas was like yeah you could pop
out then he starts dancing and I thought
it was funny for about thirty seconds
then I got nervous I was like damn what
if his penis does pop out I don't have a
back-up plan for that no teacher does
right cuz the penis is not like an
iPhone you can't stand up and say hey
either put that away I'll take it
[Music]
probably the only thing you can do in
that situation is probably call the
principal back up just tell them hey
listen listen the kid with the pajamas
he's in here his thing is out I don't
know what to do what should I do
just wait for him to say what do you
think you should do it and listen guys
that's been all my time I never go down
the Baxter thank you
you